welcome to this video playing a five
minute game on icc playing against a
teammate of mine again let's see what
can I do here we have this kind of thing
probably I play classical opening let's
see what we get we can get yeah we get
ready set up yeah a five is one way to
deal with this way early be three it's
not it is sometimes I'm given us a very
good for black I mean not like an
advantage but yeah as very
satisfactorily very satisfactory I'm not
totally sure about it Adam sometimes
still is is problematic for black to get
them get all these pieces nicely
developed especially the the bishop on c
aid i will i try to to get this in with
b6 which would be seven right be4 i have
weakened before a little bit with my a5
a4 maneuver but still it's a very
comfortable position for wide you can
play for you forward a half night be
form this is not to be underestimated
you
okay lettuce nidus it looks nice but
it's not doing that much so it's no
there's no reason to get overly
optimistic here my to e5 what exactly is
the plan if he allows me to play oh he
allows me to play deform yeah that's not
that that big a deal actually can also
play this move here which it probably
needs know where you can just move the
Queen we are not that much that I can do
about this mmm i would like to would
like to get a little bit to get this
night trade it I go 97 year I should get
g7 out of this bishops arranged so that
i can play 97 later i think this is just
about equal it's not much going on but
okay those kind of those positions still
each end plate
yeah five
let's cover a five at least for the time
being and it's not very ambitious really
I mean it's the leak wire but at least
my king is somewhat more active I want
to play be five maybe be 50 as mentioned
it is it still should be about equal
okay i can i can do that i mean it
probably not it does not need to take
but I expected him to do it anyway push
our probes to d6 try to win some space
yeah
maybe I can get in Bishop a five Bishop
you one check Bishop's III i will take
y'all to check play this Jack for
minimal advantage but let me be precise
here I want one more porn on a light
square here it will probably not met
them very much but this is if I allow
him to take and play before that that's
not so great okay i still have ideas
will put as much as possible on dark
squares and now and not a king over to a
five this is the the idea that i still
have here but this miss bishop is nicely
placed so it shouldn't be the end of the
world for white really not yeah that's
six I have to do it
you should see FOIA should be sufficient
the ship's is six yeah probably still we
are you just trying to batten down the
hatches here but it is probably enough I
don't have any reserve temper temper
images and maybe i can probably not he
has this he has this reserve move f3
and I can see can still play three exits
video really a dead position there any
way to now it is just the drawl right
there is no no way here and Bishop time
warning all right you can just you can
really just totally shuttle I have
nowhere no idea ha ha ha ha ha ha
sometimes you just mean that sort of
thing make the wrong clicks yeah so he
cannot agree that wrong yeah it was a
little bit better here for blanket but
Jack I may be screwed it up I mean ok
it's it's it's equipment maybe I can
simply cannot cannot do anything serious
but of course um if anybody black is
better I think g5 should be should be
right yeah putting this on a dark square
he went here and maybe around here Islam
is the issue hmm
I wanted to prevent him from taking and
play before maybe this is wrong maybe
that's wrong I mean it's it's been
probably just to draw any way but hmm
this is what the computer wants to play
this is I thought that this should be
something that helps white maybe I'm
wrong it's possible
I can try to get to the pawn
check now that that that gets really
really ugly for what yeah maybe there
was when somewhere with with super
precise play when I didn't see it okay
thanks for watching